padres have taken the field tonight in
san diego led by their starting pitcher
to nelson lamette making his ninth start
of the year for the padres and the 28
year old i get choked up just talking
about it because the nelson lumet is
having such a great season swing and a
miss and lament with his first k in the
night one down he's got that slider
working tonight watch out rocky hitters
because that has serious depth to it one
down here in the first inning brings up
trevor story and that strikes
99 and on the corner that'll work
back-to-back case to start the night for
nelson lamette two down brings up
charlie blackman to first base and
hosmer will take it himself to the bag
and that is that in the first inning
kyle freeland the first part of this
season he was lights out last couple
have been rough goes for he'll get
fernando tatis junior who swings at the
first pitch sends it way up in the air
to shallow left field and sam hilliard
makes the catch one down here in the
first inning manny machado out of the
two spot for the padres that's ball four
and the chat will head down to first
base walk given up by kyle friedland is
a one-out free pass if you're in the
first inning and that'll bring up eric
weigh in that hit has i could hear from
here not just the hit but out hosmer in
some pain he took one off it looks like
the left index finger insult to injury
they're saying he is out yeah because he
offered at it and it hit him so it's a
dead ball strikeout they might have to
go get that those x-rayed so that was a
strikeout of hosmer and with two down
here in the inning machado still at
first nola
goes it first pitches a strike throw
down there and
safe at second base is machado stolen
base
able to get into scoring position with
the theft of second base nola breaks his
bat a little looper to trevor story for
the third out a little bit of a change
in the lineup if we saw eric hosmer take
that bun attempt off the left hand he
has left the ball game mitch moreland
will now be playing first base for the
padres it's runners on first and second
with one out here in the third inning a
leadoff hitter rymel tapia coming up
swung on grounded the third manny diving
stop tags the runner yes or no yes throw
to first in time double play what a play
manny machado and for the second time in
his many innings a big time double play
padres have back-to-back singles with
one out against freeland here in the
third in this nothing nothing ball game
and if andre's in some business with
manny machado coming up swung on and hit
high in the air shallow left field
hilliard coming in makes the catch and
on one pitch machado is the second out
good job by freeland to retire manny and
that'll bring up mitch borland runners
go one hopper right back to freeland
gloves it throws to first and works out
of trouble in the third seventh story
leading it off here for the colorado
rockies in the fourth inning swinging
miss story went chasing a slider and
strikeout number three for denelson one
out here in the top of the fourth inning
swinging a miss goes after that slider
down and in back-to-back strikeouts for
the met ball got away from nola but he
picks it up and throws down to first
base to complete the put out number four
on the night for
lumet and now runners on first and
second two away for the switch hitter
profile let's see if kyle can come all
the way back and finish off pro far and
finish off the inning and it's on the
ground a second mcmahon's got it
and no harm done so kyle freeland bears
down and gets pro far in a big situation
now for the fifth inning and more of the
same for nelson lament is not allowed to
run through four he hasn't given up a
run this year in each of the first two
innings not once not one time that's
strike three that's a good pitch that's
the fifth strikeout for denelson lumet
two down to the fifth inning spider
swinging the miss i don't mean to laugh
but it's just ridiculous
he was one
who steps off the mound
after he released the ball and that's
not
that's not ego that's just confidence
that is the third walk freeland has
allowed and you've got a really good
base stealer now with a hot hitter and
machado with the plate the runner goes
in tatis pitches a strike throw down
there and titans get away into center
field he'll keep going and fernando will
have a stolen base and an e2 on the
throws gets to
third with one out first member of the
padres to reach third base in this game
swaying in a miss he got him with a
nasty slider what a strikeout there for
a big second out now it's moreland swang
and a miss he got him with this slider
kyle freeland with back to back
strikeouts with a runner at third the
nelson lamette has again right now a
little uh four hit shutout
11.79 strikeouts for nine innings like
this one right here guess what of course
the slider unhittable that's seven
strikeouts for lumet
three in a row
swing and a miss and make it eight
strikeouts for lumet and four in a row
forever story hole for two trevor story
with a two out double first extra base
hit for either side in this one breaks
up a string of seven in a row retired by
lumet
and charlie blackman with a chance to
get the rockies the game's first run he
went around that is strike three and oh
my gosh 79 the strikeouts in this inning
for the nelson lament andre's have the
first two men aboard here in the seventh
with one out and fernando tati's junior
coming up hit him slider came in it hit
him and he is holding his arm or wrist
or hand maybe forearm hopefully forearm
and it's obviously one of the scariest
things you can imagine for the padres
right now he will stay in the game and
the bases are loaded for machado
scoreless in the bottom of the seventh
inning one out and that is caught
throwback to first
save
i believe this would be reviewed oh he's
yeah his foot's on his back
that isn't even particularly close
and the rockies survive the seventh
nelson lumet is out there to start the
eighth never in his career has he
recorded an out in the eighth strike
three call strikeout number 10 of the
night for danel should lament out number
one in the eighth inning seven and a
third a career high for nelson lament
strike three call make it 11 k's for
janelle sandleman potential single for
matt kemp with two outs here in the
eighth inning keeps the inning alive for
the rockies and maybe the end of the
evening for lumet longest outing of his
career for denelson lameet but a leadoff
single starts things in the bottom of
the ninth inning for the friars jorge
mateo will pinch run at first base it
would be
really nice to see somebody split a gap
here and watch that kid run so here is
profar profile lines it into right field
that's going to get in and roll towards
the corner matteo headed for third
matteo be waved around by hoffman the
throw to the plate will be late and the
padres will walk it off in san diego
tonight jericho with the base hit padres
winning one nothing